targaryens are a valerian descent and
the freehold of valeria was the
you know the superpower of my my world
for hundreds of years
uh there were sorcerer lords there who
who controlled certain dark magics blood
magic
and fire magic pyromancy
and one of the things they had was
dragons and they were great dragon lord
families that bred and controlled
dragons and
and flew them into battle and they they
competed for primacy
um most of the rest of the
known world could not stand against the
valyrians even when they had larger
armies the the
valerian advantage of dragons was was
too great to
overcome but
400 years ago the doom came the doom of
valeria
and the entire freehold of valeria was
was wiped out overnight um and the
dragonlords and hundreds of dragons with
it
the targaryens had been one of the the
families
one of the oligarchy but they
had had a premonition and something like
this in common and they had resettled to
the dragonstone island off the coast of
westeros
sometime before the the doom came to
valeria and thereby
avoided that and and it left them after
a relatively short period with the only
effective dragons in there in the world
and
aegon and his sisters used uh
three of those dragons to conquer the
the seven kingdoms of westeros
when aegon the conqueror came
and he conquered most of the southern
kingdoms
tauren stark had come south
with a large army of north men to
confront him but after the field for
fire he knew it was doomed and
so he knelt and he was the last king of
the north and the first
who was simply lord of winterfell and a
vassal
of the iron throne ruling as a
as a secondary ruler subject to the
the laws of the targaryens
the targaryens conquered the seven
kingdoms with
dragons but then
during the later civil war called the
dance with the dragons
the majority of those dragons were
killed
and the few that survived that war died
a relatively short time later or
else left the known lands of westeros
um so by that point the targaryens were
firmly established as the kings and
had you know the power
of tradition and legitimacy behind them
generations had come up of age with the
idea of the targaryens were the king
and
that the rules didn't apply to them i
mean that was also part of it
targaryens were interlopers from another
culture and they had some
um unique factors that didn't
necessarily fit into
the mainstream of the other westerosi
lords such as their
traditional incest uh you know which was
part of keeping the bloodlines
pure so that they could uh better
control the the dragon's brother
marrying sister and
and you know um nephews and
aunts and so forth
king aegon iv also known as aegon the
unworthy
um had a lot of bastards everywhere he
went
he uh he fathered children
on serving wenches and tavern girls but
also on the
daughters and wives of noblemen um
and he only had one well he had he had
uh
had one son by his legitimate wife who
was also his sister
in the targaryen thing and that was his
legitimate heir
but he didn't actually like that kid
very much and he liked some of his
bastards better
and uh he was you know he was not a
popular king aegon and worthy you could
probably guess it from his name
and he made a lot of trouble for seven
kingdoms because on his deathbed he
legitimized all of his bastards
and uh then that created the question of
okay now they're legitimate they're not
bastards where do they fall in the line
of succession
and the one of the oldest bastards who
was a splendid
uh you know looked like a targaryen um
great warrior charismatic handsome
um
he gave blackfyre which is that
ancestral sword of aegon to conquer and
all the targaryen kings
and he presented the sword to to his son
who was the warrior son the the son who
was the crown prince was not much of a
warrior so
in some sense he was giving the sword to
the son
who was best fit to to use it
but that created the issue well does the
sword represent the kingdom
was he saying this son should be my heir
he was unclear on that point and
uh when you're unclear on that point in
the middle ages you normally got a war
indeed that's what happened here aegon
and his supporters rose up
or damon and his supporters rose up
after after aegon's death
against his half brother
uh darren and uh there was the first of
the blackfyre rebellions
and it was followed by uh four more
blackfire rebellions because uh
damon blackfire fathered children of his
own and there was a whole
another line of pretenders to
the blackfyre pretenders that
periodically would
come invading westeros and say no no
we're the legitimate kings and they
would try to overthrow the targaryens
and this was all after the dragons had
dined out so i mean in the days when
there were dragons the targaryens
might have been able to deal with this a
little more easily but
uh without dragons it's all a question
of who can raise the biggest armies and
who can win the support of the the
powerful lords and the populists
etc this book only goes up to the
regency of aegon and ends when aegon iii
actually reaches man and takes control
so i have his reign to cover
which includes the death of the last
dragons although aegon iii is called the
dragon bane there are still
three or four dragons kicking around
when he takes the crown and there are
none by the time he's over so
that one thing i was going to cover why
and what happens there and some of the
troubles and rebellions of his reign
and then ultimately his children who are
fairly interesting i mean he has
ultimately
five one of whom is
there on the first a young dragon who
conquers dorne
uh and he's a 14 year old alexander the
great kind of
hero king figure uh but he dies young
and then his his brother baylor takes
over
and baylor is uh very religious very
he's
more of a st louis kind of figure um
a little extreme in his religiosity and
among other things he he uh imprisons
his three sisters in
luxurious imprisonment in the red keep
the maidenhold but he doesn't like them
like walking around court because they
tempt him
so i'll tell their stories and i'll tell
baylor's story and then
after him will we get a brief a brief
reign of viserys the second
um and then visery's son aegon the
fourth aegon the unworthy takes over and
he's a
a very colorful figure himself i
obviously
drew on henry the eighth for him you
know henry the eighth had six wives
aegon the unworthy had nine mistresses
and they were all exist in my head i
know who they all were and what happened
to each of them and who was
who had their head chopped off and who
uh you know had affairs and who did what
so there's a lot of
cool material that and then you get into
the blackfyre rebellions
which were five i've referred to them
frequently
so i'll get all the details on the
blackfyre rebellions and
ultimately we'll get up to the the mad
king and robert's rebellion
and wow that's where i'll draw it to a
close
by the time this comes around the
targaryens
have not had dragons for a long time
and and i guess robert and some of the
other lords are starting to say you know
we don't
really have to be that afraid of these
guys anymore they can no longer
you know just fly overhead and burn down
our castles our entire cities and
it's beginning to just this is beginning
to dawn
into it that maybe the targaryens are
just people like other people
and not uh an outside alien force with
uh
with strange scaly superpowers
ned stark is a very honorable man
you know when there are certain things
that bother him and one of them
is the killing of children
this produced a rift
between robert and him during back
during the rebellion when
king's landing fell and the lannister
men
killed prince rhaegar's two young
children
and laid wrapped a little bodies and
cloaks and presented them to robert
ned was sickened by this and quarreled
with robert over it
is violence ever justified to oppose
evil in the world
if so to what extent is violence
justified
um and these are the questions that ned
and robert had to uh
had to deal with there was no doubt that
the mad king was mad he he was
you know paranoid and violent and he was
abusing his power
and westeros has no magna carta or
anything like that there was
no way to handle this within the rule of
law
but was what they do
justified the execution of ned's father
and and brother was really a thing that
radicalized as we would have said in the
60s
ned and men put him uh in in opposition
to it
robert was just rolling for a fight
that's mostly about the targaryen kings
and the whole history of westeros
[Music]
you